vsauce kevin here and i've combined one
of the deadliest games anyone can play
with one
of the stupidest which is why i will
need two complete morons to play it
thomas edison and nicola tesla okay
they're actually two of the most
legendary geniuses of all time but their
rivalry was serious especially over
tesla's alternating current ac
electricity and edison's direct current
dc which we now call the war of the
currents throw in decades of personal
disputes and
they've got a score to settle their
balloon avatars will fight to the death
with the help of a toy revolver and a
single needle dart they'll be playing a
form of russian roulette watch my
surviving the deadliest game video for
the math on the original and the
stupidest game humans have played is
probably the classic duel where two
people just stand there and
shoot at each other
i'm guard
that's that's fencing but
you know what i mean these two titans of
the electron are gonna duel with
this one gun russian roulette style okay
the game is simple player a loads the
cartridge spins the cylinder and shoots
at player b
he's so close that it's impossible to
miss the gun will either fire and he'll
win or
not
if it doesn't fire he hands the gun to
player b who then spins the cylinder
again and then shoots at player a
then eventually it goes on until one of
them is crowned the emperor of
electricity first off
don't try this actual game please
especially because i'll show you exactly
how to try this actual game without
trying this actual game anyway for now
what we really want to know is who's
more likely to win edison or tesla
someone's got to go first so i'll use an
unbiased coin flip to determine the
order heads for edison tails for tesla
here we go
heads for edison
edison
all right here we go first shot for
edison to tesla
wait
to figure out whether there's an
advantage to going first we can just map
out the scenarios in which edison wins
we don't even need numbers sorry numbers
let's use e for when the gun fires for
edison and an x for when the gun does
not fire here's a map of all the
possible edison victories this goes on
until the gun fires ease can only fall
on the odd rounds because edison went
first and that's really the difference
here edison and tesla have the same
chance of winning every round one out of
six but edison can win on the very first
round before tesla even gets a turn
that's a major advantage but
how much and how has this first round
advantage caused one of the biggest
games in the world to literally change
its rules we'll get to that later for
now it's time for edison's first shot we
re-spin the old revolver here
here we go
tesla survives
okay
round wait wait let's think about this
the probability of edison firing the gun
is one over six from the first round
plus the probability of success in
subsequent rounds and this goes on and
on as long as edison and tesla keep
missing spoiler the total probability of
the gun firing for edison comes out to 6
over 11 or
.5454 repeating so edison's got a
54.5 chance of winning this duel which
means tesla tesla is at just 45.5
that's a 9 disadvantage
for tesla even in this
balloon rivalry the deck is stacked in
favor of edison you can calculate
manually how many trigger pulls are in
the average game of idiots russian
roulette but paul j nahin's monte carlo
simulations of 10 000 trials confirmed
that it's about six here's what's
interesting about two-thirds of those
games are over in the first six rounds
there's a long tale with some games
going 20 or 30 rounds but it's generally
a quick game so edison getting that
first shot
really matters wait you can actually run
russian roulette simulations yourself
without a computer program or anything
more dangerous you've got a random
number generator in your pocket open the
stopwatch divide a second into six 0.01
to 0.17
corresponds to the gun firing 0.18
to 0.00 means it doesn't fire
start the stopwatch close your eyes and
stop it the decimal value of the seconds
is a random firing simulator that you
can use to map out russian roulette
safely but now it's time to get back to
our game and it's time
for tesla's revenge here we go
hold on if tesla going second means that
he's at such a disadvantage
how can we make the game more fair we
can't just play it 1000 times
alternating who gets to go first so that
the advantages even out someone's
getting popped
we get
one shot at this so let's just change
the rules to compensate for giving
edison the first shot new game if
edison's gun doesn't fire in round one
tesla gets two shots if neither of
tesla's shots fire edison gets three
shots this goes on until the gun fires
does that actually make the game more
fair is giving tesla an additional shot
after round one enough to make up for
his disadvantage new map okay there's
the map of our new version of the game
and we can do the same sort of
calculation as before but the
probability of edison's gun firing is
now
that
with an exponent corresponding to each
of edison's rounds the alternating
expanding rounds model reduces edison's
chance of winning all the way down to
about
52.4
that's two points lower for edison and
two points higher for all tesla here
who's now sitting at 47.6
it's better it's not great but it's
better we can keep tweaking the rules we
can keep
running the math but the most critical
part of the deadliest dumbest game might
not be
how it's played but actually
that coin flip that determines
who goes first which is what the
national football league one of the most
popular sports leagues in the world
realized when it changed its sudden
death overtime rules in 2010. the team
who got the ball first won the game so
often that not winning the coin toss to
determine who played offense first meant
you'd lose the game nearly three
out of five
times but check this out look what i
found you're not gonna believe this and
if you do i won't believe you all right
look when the nfl used sudden death
overtime rules coin flip winners won 52
percent of the time coin flip losers won
43.4 percent of the time the other 4.6
percent were ties if we evenly
distributed those ties as wins that's
54.3
to the coin flip winner and 45.7
for the loser sound familiar those are
almost the exact same odds of our
original edison tesla duel game look at
that look at it
maybe that's why they called this sudden
death all right let's settle this duel
once and for all here we go okay so
using our new game rules tesla actually
gets another shot all right shot number
two for tesla here we go
feel lucky edison
oh
edison survives now it goes back to
edison's turn that's two misses for
tesla here we go now edison gets three
shots say your prayers tesla
you're gonna need them
[Music]
survives once again okay
two more shots for
edison here we go
[Music]
no
survives another one
all right one more for edison and then
it's going back
to tesla
here we are
oh
he made it through round two now tesla
gets four
tries
edison
you really should have done it that time
four shots for tesla shot number one
[Music]
shot number one survived
shot number
ah
two
number two this game maybe we'll make it
to uh 30 rounds here we go
spinning the shot number three
for tesla
number three the game continues
shot number four chance number four
you'd think one of these four would be
it let's find out
i can't believe it i can't believe it
four down now it goes to five shots for
edison
shot number one
for edison
[Music]
alright the game continues the game
continues shot number two
[Music]
jeez
you thinking
one of these would be it
not so not so i'm totally randomizing
this folks no
no funny games here
shot number three
[Music]
tesla no
no
i am so sorry i am sorry you have been
reduced to this this is all that's left
of nikola tesla just a dressed up
pringles can
is all we have left well
there you go
edison wins
the numbers worked
i've got nothing more to say
other than and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]
you